par ses combats tu peux me classer comme
j'ai commencé en tant que graphiste
c'est comme ça que je suis rentré un peu
dans la musique notamment par le biais
d'artistes indépendants et quand j'ai
commencé à fait à faire un petit peu de
vidéo ici à la réunion
g
est intacte et du coup les contacts que
j'avais sur sur paris donc j'ai commencé
les clips vidéo de ça j'ai fait
plusieurs clips pour blake et j'ai fait
le dernier grand paris de médine avec
ont baladé au chaud puccino et compagnie
elle n'arrête pas de me demander
pourquoi je suis venu ici alors qu'il ya
des saules et chez eux j'ai quitté la
réunion pour les études
j'ai fait une formation en alternance
3 sur paris c'est
à côté à côté de ça en fait où je
faisais des clips et donc du coup bah ça
a pris le pas et ça fait que je suis
resté là bas au final géant du soleil 30
degrés en moyenne toute la semaine pour
le moment je suis dans jambon 60 jours
même quand je vais occuper aujourd'hui
justement l'idée ce serait de d'associer
au fait la production audiovisuelle à la
production musicale est effectivement
moi qui à la base suis passionné de
musique pas c'est vraiment ça qui me
fait vibrer je ferai du surf sur la
vague de leur du littoral en kata l'idée
c'est aussi de pouvoir collaborer avec
un tas d'artistes différents auxquels on
ne verrait pas forcément auquel on
associerait pas forcément et pas
forcément être contenté de rester dans
le registre des gens qui m'appellent au
fait difficilement dans tous les cas
même dans les morceaux on retrouvera
toujours des petites références
ce sont autant dans la musicalité ça
peut être
faire intervenir des rouleurs des
cailloux que ce soit dans les textes 11
ans des références aux aux paysages
d'ici ou alors des des expressions jour
là je croyais toujours vos rêves de la
charia et battait jusqu'au cou
[Musique]